[Musik]
am Donnerstag übernimmt general Rudolf
Striedinger in Anwesenheit von
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tanner
im Rahmen eines militärischen Festaktes
in der maria-theresien-kaserne offiziell
sein neues Amt als Chef des Generalstabs
für mich ist das ein besonderer Ort die
maria-theresien-kaserne
vor drei Wochen gut drei Wochen und 43
Jahren
bin ich hier durch dieses Kasernentor
gegangen
und habe in diesem Blog da hinten meine
ersten Schritte als EF
Grundwehrdiener wer man Striedinger
begonnen
ein weiter Weg 43 Jahre von Beginn
meiner militärischen Laufbahn bis
hierher an die Spitze
vertrauen ist das Lebenselixier
freier demokratischer Gesellschaften und
genau deswegen bedanke ich mich bei dir
Frau Bundesministerin dass du das
Vertrauen in mich gesetzt hast
und dich dann für mich entschieden hast
vielen Dank dafür
abschließend möchte ich mich bei allen
kommandantinnen Kommandanten Leiterinnen
und Leitern
die mich durch die letzten Monate
getragen haben seitdem generell Brieger
in Brüssel ist wirklich sehr herzlich
bedanken für die
großartige loyale und kameradschaftliche
Unterstützung keine
Selbstverständlichkeit weiß man doch
nicht wer dann wirklich vorne steht
in diesem Sinne
hoffe ich in allen zu
gehen wir es an zum Wohle des
österreichischen Bundesheeres dankeschön
[Applaus]